We've seen how acceleration scales with force--they're proportional--
but what about mass?
How does mass affect acceleration?
The experiment I want to do now is slightly different.
Instead of changing the force, we're going to change the mass and leave the force the same
through all the trials of our experiment.
Can you look at this data, keeping in mind that, of course, the force is staying the same,
calculate the accelerations, and then tell me how does the acceleration scale with m
or how does it depend on the mass.
Which of these best describes how acceleration scales with m?
And you may need this equation to help you out.